and we're going to stay in india that
country has administered its billionth
covet 19 vaccine dose six months after
surge in cases brought its health system
close to collapse about three-quarters
of adults have now had one shot and
around 30 percent are fully vaccinated
however hundreds of millions of indians
under 18 who make up some 40 percent of
the population have not yet been
vaccinated
and i'd like to now welcome gautama
menon a professor of biophysics at
india's ashoka university professor a
very warm welcome to dw news 1 billion
shots i mean that is truly a milestone
but when less than one-third of india's
population is fully vaccinated is this
really a cause for celebration
well it's a milestone and certainly a
few months ago it didn't seem as though
we might reach there when vaccination
rates were flagging so i think it's
important to note that at least 75
percent of the adult population of india
has some level of protection either been
through being fully vaccinated or
partially vaccinated and that's at least
a step forward and it should help to
slow
any potential third wave that might be
waiting for us we have to worry now
about the 25 which have not been
vaccinated yet and how to ensure that
they're vaccinated fast over the coming
weeks professor can you tell us and fill
us in about how the pandemic is evolving
in india
right now numbers are very small they're
certainly very small across much of the
north of india there's still there there
is one southern state in particular the
state of kerala where numbers have been
reducing after staying fairly steady at
about 20 000 to 30 000 cases for quite
quite a while now it's dipped well below
that
so it looks as though the pandemic is on
its way out at least for the time being
in india because the case load has
significantly reduced and the test
positivity is really low at the moment
and what are the the biggest challenges
right now that india faces when it comes
to tackling the pandemic
we'll have to see in a few weeks because
right now this is festival season in
india that the big festival is unfolding
at the moment whether people will let
down their caution at this period and
that whether that might lead to a rise
in cases and potentially initiate
another wave that could be large is
something that still we don't know so we
will know this in the weeks to come
whether extended mixing that we will see
in this period might have longer term
consequences and is there also a
difference between how the pandemic has
evolved in in rural areas and in urban
areas
in in the second wave which was really
the devastating wave that crossed much
of india the distinction between urban
and rural was pretty much wiped out and
rural india saw a lot of debts
unrecorded deaths at that point so i
think now there isn't too much of a
difference between urban and rural parts
of india as far as infections prior
infections go
and that certainly is a different from
what happened in the first week which
really hit the city is much more than it
did the villages
and professors and final thoughts from
you
what's your assessment of the indian
government's handling of the pandemic so
far
the handling has been good in recent
weeks and months i'd say because we have
now ramped up vaccination rates to above
somewhere between 10 to 20 million per
day which is pretty good right now it's
a little low but that's the number that
we've sustained from about two weeks ago
and before that the handling of the
second wave of the pandemic left much to
be desired that was a place where really
cases exploded across the country and
the health system pretty much gave up at
that point so i think i hope lessons
from that have now been learned lessons
that are really about strengthening the
public health system overall in india
and i hope that that's one lesson that
we take forward into the future
professor gautam menon of india's ashoka
university sir thank you for your
time thank you